didn't like all this stuff all the time  but we're not and what I realized is  that the violence against women is  that's a business  and please expound yeah so there's  millions of dollars that goes into you  have to follow the money there's like  all these organizations that have the  same patterns so it's like violence  against women  um BLM the freaking  um environmental stuff it's the same  pattern well they're complain about a  problem not really have a solution these  guys are bad and it's like what they'll  do is there are incentives to like keep  these problems alive because there's so  much money in it and I don't know like  all the ins and outs of it but it's it's  like once you see it you can unsee it  like there's just these it's like a  pattern and it's the same like rhetoric  they use for violence against women that  they would use like even even for the  freaking environment